[Music]  okay Olaf you're up unicorn oh I don't  think I should get to rearrange doesn't  matter this is gonna be a cinch  Oh distracted worried  [Music]  how's Elsa seemed weird to you  she seems like Elsa there's just voice  voice what does that mean  the kingdom is not safe find who is  calling to you they may have answers  across the enchanted lands and into the  unknown we do this together okay  the spirits will challenge your every  step of the way  [Music]  that's normal  who are you I'm a lot oh sorry yeah I  just find clothes restricting  should I know what that means  the giant huge  I don't scream  magic disappearing without you she may  lose herself to it I believe in you more  than anyone or anything  if anyone can save arendelle it's you  how do you guys cope with the ever  increasing complexity of thought that  comes with maturity oh no no no don't  you that you don't know what I stepped  it  [Music]